[Music]
yeah that's me
you may be wondering how i got here
receiving a flying
pile driver from three miles up into an
active volcano for my nemesis
well i'd like to think it all started
back in high school
transformers is a franchise that gets a
bad rep because while every other
ridiculous but fun
idea from the previous century started
getting a better mainstream adaptation
transformers lagged behind with the same
2000s directorial style where it was
simultaneously embarrassed by the source
material
and trying to make it more embarrassing
to improve it and while eventually the
movie's got a fresh new lease on life i
feel as if a lot of people hear
transformers and roll their eyes that
anyone could like a shameless toy
commercial
but i'm here today to tell you that it
ain't like that man you just gotta
give it a chance i have some great
memories of this franchise and after
revisiting a bit of it as i got older i
can definitely say some of it doesn't
hold up
but plenty of it does one of my favorite
examples being this
wonderful little game on ps2 where
megatron can kick your lifeless ragdoll
body into an active volcano
and his voice is so buttery smooth you
swoon and ask for another
[Music]
i would have waited an eternity for this
i like this shameless toy commercial and
speaking of
it's been quite a while since we've seen
a game with transformers on modern
consoles but this video's incredibly
generous sponsor wants to let us know
that we're one step closer with the new
update for the game
world of warships legends now featuring
100
more prime world of warships is a
free-to-play free-to-win
mmo action game about world war one and
world war ii
inspired naval battles and you can
download it free today on your console
of choice
the ui and controls are specially
adapted to feel comfortable to play on
consoles and i was able to get the hang
of the smooth controls pretty much
instantly when i tried it out myself
this game is also very colorful and
graphically polished with great sound
design to give you a sense of where the
battle's at
and having two playable autobots and
decepticons each makes this one worth
checking out for any transformers fans
hungry for new gaming content with these
characters
you can check out four new transformers
themed ship skins for optimus bumblebee
megatron
and rumble with special animations
unique voice lines for their commanders
you can also get bundles of content that
appeal most to you
with unique commanders permanent
camouflages containers and more
each bundle comes with a special
challenge from each of the game's new
factions
the autobots and decepticons and the
rewards for those challenges are special
patches
if you want to try out the game and get
a head start on progression
check out the link in the description to
get 75 000 credits a premium tier two
ship
and three days of a premium account when
you sign up for the game
now back to some older autobots and
warships yes i'm working on a review of
the avengers game but it turns out i had
quite a lot to say about that one
it's going to take a bit longer than
expected so you better watch it when it
comes out or you're all uninvited to my
birthday party
but in the meantime i want to spotlight
a game that's very near and dear to my
heart
transformers on ps2 which
should have a subtitle because it's
based on transformers armada but i guess
not that's never not confusing
transformers armada also known as super
robot lifeform transformers legend of
the microns
was the anime then introduced and
subsequently wouldn't shut up about the
minicons
are the pawns in our battle the minicons
have been revived here on earth
the future you know transformers well
here's those but smaller mini cons can
attach to your lower extremities and
make you more attractive to optimus
prime senpai if you collect enough mini
guns to become optimus primal for your
final tuned robotic figure
the minicon signal originated from this
position
search the area the game follows suit by
having the plot and main gameplay
mechanics tied to the use of these
smaller transformers that can attach to
bigger transformers and be used to boost
their power that sounds like the most
toyatic [ __ ] ever you gotta love it
this is also the anime that got a bunch
of canadian voice actors for the dub
including ed ednetty you rotten liar
you broke your promise without my friend
right now or not
radar's picked up some unidentified
bogeys coming at us oh man you guys are
wicked cool especially the way you can
transform like that
and beast wars optimus and megatron the
game has none of these human characters
so none of that was relevant but hey i'm
a sucker for transformers material with
the absolute minimum of annoying teenage
sidekicks
and as such beast wars is my favorite
transformer series by elonshot
i don't know if this may be sacrilege to
the transformers fandom but i think gary
chalk and david k
are great as these characters and i
always enjoy hearing their optimus in
megatron even if they aren't the classic
lineup of
the predator and scooby-doo did you know
optimus primal was in the sonic movie
he was also in this video
missed it by that much i wish i could
turn into a red and blue
submarine game starts with a good old
flashback to the war on cybertron as
most transformers media does
the fan favorite hippie robot underdogs
battle their authoritarian space racist
counterparts in a flashy battle of
lasers and punching the battle is
interrupted by a distress signal from
those rascally minicons who crash-landed
on earth this causes both leaders to
rush to the strange new world in search
of free labor from smaller robots
they help build our cities and our
industries on cybertron
they were built and designed to be
workers they are nothing but
slaves hey so if minicons are the same
size as people
does that mean frenzy was a mini con
what about that mean girl decepticon
that shia labeouf almost made sweet
sugary love to
was that a mini con if decepticons could
just disguise themselves as people then
why didn't they all do that they could
have just had this
chick pretend to be obama and then tell
everyone that the decepticons seemed
like pretty cool guys
so anyway we get to the game and it
feels like this is the first 3d game to
really nail down how a transformer
should feel
you get a great sense of the weight and
scale of these characters from your
tank-like movements and heavy jumping
with the l1 button
i could see these controls turning some
people off to the game but i think they
do a really great job of conveying the
way it would feel to move as a giant
robot
you don't have that weightless ninja
agility that they all seem to have in
the movies
the shooting is some pretty standard run
gun but you get this first person mode
to zoom in close
the fact that this mode limits your walk
speed by making you crouch
means it's more meant just in case
you're trying to snipe some bad robots
at a distance
and the game can't really be played this
way all the time your movement speed and
melee attacks change depending on which
of the three autobots you pick
you have your choice of hopeful chief
not bumblebee but basically bumblebee
and robocop all right i'll trust you
but only if you will perform oral sex on
me
this is my serious face as for our
vehicle movement you can transmorphify
into a vehicle corresponding to your
alien chevy sponsor
this vehicle stuff is kind of
utilitarian and wouldn't affect the game
much to remove it
there aren't as many sections where you
get a lot of wide open space or flat
terrain to drive on
so it's better to hoof it though
sometimes it serves its purpose to help
you cover ground more quickly if you're
being chased by a boss or feeling
overwhelmed by enemies
because the decepticon soldiers can't
transform at all
say for the named bosses the shooting
mechanics are interesting because
all of the back buttons on the
controller are associated with a
different power
you have your main weapon a secondary a
power buff
or a status effect and something else
tied to traversal
every mini con you pick up gives you a
different flavor of one of these four
traits
it's really fun to mix and match
different builds for different missions
it's a simple system but it gives you a
lot of customization options without
being overly complicated
this game has the best rag doll of any
game ever
look at these transformers limpy rolling
around like their bones have been
shattered
i've never been so happy to be made of
metal
i think what makes this game so
memorable for me is the levels and
variety of locations
you have a lot of secluded set pieces
where transformers are allowed to fight
each other without human involvement
and these locations are really pretty
despite their blocky ps2 graphics
there's locations like the amazon
rainforest antarctica
a tropical island and the alaskan
mountains
as well as locations more tied to the
robots themselves
like a decepticon aircraft carrier a
flying battleship and eventually the
skies of cybertron some of my favorite
levels are the fight on top of the
pyramid and the decepticon cruiser
you have to go through this level twice
once while it's in operational order
and another time when you've crashed it
straight into the ground the level is
really cleverly designed so you can
still navigate around this place while
it's now in a vertical position
the bosses aren't exactly plentiful but
they give them the coolest intro cut
scenes to really hype up the fight
you're about to deal with
they have a hilarious habit of doing
wrestling moves on you if you get too
close
i love this level where you infiltrate a
decepticon aircraft carrier
battle through hordes of enemies and
then notice something in this window
hey wait a minute that that kinda looks
like a face then after you've proceeded
far
enough you find out the aircraft carrier
itself
is also a decepticon i've said it before
but i
love boss encounters where you're a
small character fighting a giant
i'd like to formally extend the truth as
i think he'd be perfect for my
basketball team tidal wave
well i just thought it'd be polite to
ask
well most often these types of boss
fights are handled with a boring qte
a lot of them are like a one of these
you know the boss fights that are a one
of this
there are a lot of these top 10 boss
fights that are on this
number ten this one number nine this one
number eight this one but not here you
and tidal wave both have a full range of
movement around this massive
area you'll find yourself messing your
robotic drawers as he lumbers towards
you
you also get to fight starscream twice
and megatron is one of the coolest boss
fights in history
he can do this
that move is so cool i ain't even mad
the final boss is a giant orange orson
wells ball that launches a devastating
gender reveal party on cybertron that
you stop with all your combined powers
remember that time unicron was the
center of the earth and if he
transformed it would kill everyone and
then the movies were gonna do that too
but then it got cancelled
my favorite genre of film is post
credits scene teasing a sequel that
never happened
[Music]
to top it off this game's action is
really enhanced by just how
awesome this soundtrack is this game's
not exactly super complicated but it's
insanely nostalgic and memorable for me
and i had a lot of fun watching my dad
play it when i was a kid
it was one of the things that got me
interested in transformers and video
games in general
so it was an interesting one to revisit
if you can hunt down a copy i definitely
recommend trying it out
for victory victory
for cybertron
take it away optimus hey there autobots
this is optimus prime and i've
synthesized my human
english voice to match the incredibly
talented actor gary chalk
subscribe to xavier for more videos like
this one
god that is so cool i can't believe that
happened
[Music]
[Music]
you